hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play knock knock
what you see before you is not exactly
what one would call a game it's more
like an interactive meditation reenacted
from scattered evidence that happened to
fall into our hands it was built
according to instruction
left by the original archives Anonymous
you're hearing that donor many strange
things and unclear moments you will
encounter in this whatever-it-is are due
to the requirements outlined in the
archive maybe it was just a mysterious
hoax but it probably wasn't we suggest
you view it as just another urban legend
legend we recommend you play this in a
dark and quiet place alone why why would
I need to do that if it really is
nothing ok I could have sworn that I
actually heard some things in there but
let's just get into the game I've been
wanting two plates for a while two very
recent release but it's like um one of
those interactive storytelling game into
that and I I really like it because I
really like neverending nightmares and
it kind of gave me the same
heebie-jeebies about it
okay I'm in the game now okay so whoa
but a migraine as if someone is pounding
a hole in my poor skull I know he's got
his I know he's got his regular speak oh
that is so cool
I think this is definitely made on the
unity engine I've even started to
sleepwalk last night I woke up standing
right here at the door I just noticed
that face on the wall behind him if it
hadn't been bolted I would end it up
aside at this at night this door has to
be locked securely why is that I'm
trying to talk over his mumbling I mean
it's this kind of sim speaking moment
but really cool the way the shadows
interact like a 2d / 3d style
oh I'm dumped whoa things got a little
weirder what's with the skulls in the
background I'm exhausted I just can't
fall asleep and then in the dark I keep
seeing some strange things why are you
talking to me like this hold space what
am i doing whoa what am I doing here
seems like the light was working why do
I need it oh that's much better
it's not any less creepy but it one
knocking at my door no you're not gonna
say anything about that man all right
whatever you live your life how blue
yummy like that it's very strange feels
like time is standing still why doesn't
this night ever end something is very
wrong is something wrong about your
hairstyles kind of a travesty to mankind
Oh
sick burn alright anyway going on here I
think you keep doing that shimmy who's a
knock knocking
okay what weights me in the darkness
nothing apparently except a ladder to
the Attic I can't seem to move in
three-dimensional space so what okay I
thought that name was gonna happen there
what what oh okay ah I can't move in
three whoa what but in what whoa what
what what is happening I'm so confused
this is how it's done I can wind up the
time - if the morning is not coming to
me I'll move myself in my home towards
it
whoa why what is even going on about
what oh oh I think that's a good thing
man uh uh uh uh uh well there's a deal
man oh the sound of the knocking came
from here but how did I manage to unbolt
it and not lock it again what you were
just sleeping there you do knocking
didn't come from there it's frightening
to go out at night but I have to check
to make sure that it's just the wind
why that's died I'm just I don't even
know how to make commentary oh why are
you in the middle of the woods in the
middle of the night when there's trees
shaped like death and their branches are
like hands of death there's enough to go
down what why oh but why you my I'm
gonna do my little shimmy dance through
the woods
don't mind me monsters I'm gonna show
you the dance of my people ha ha ha him
in the mama nerd called the mumble dance
and my do your Butler free boy you did
alright we go I don't exactly know what
I'm looking for out here but I'm just
gonna keep trying hey you put the iodine
ok I'm done I'm done with that hyah
okay I just love my little dance here
there's nothing else to do in the woods
besides be worried about what could have
come jumping out of me at random points
but I don't see anything epic though oh
what's that over there
I see something is it a factory or is it
my house Oh what my god look I'm in
somebody's brain Addison this game is
weird
this game is thoroughly weird I have no
idea what but what what does that mean
what does that what what's that noise
it's a clock ticking I'm finally awake
now
and as usual in the early hours in the
morning it'll be sunrise soon for now
I'll just check if everything's all
right I dreamt that the front door was
unlocked someone was knocking I had to
get up and look and I regained
consciousness in the forest and I can
hardly find my way back
ah what is that what what I did it what
did I just do Oh what is this sound was
it confused really really you need to
work to get your doors open you need to
fix your house man what's that sound
who's gonna just a minute I'll wait for
my eyes to adjust why what we're not
gonna wait we gotta go
I have a feeling there's some sort of
demonic entity in this house that I'm
not gonna want to I don't even recognize
my own home why does it look so empty
it's probably just my eyes going bad my
eyesight is getting worse and worse
after dark
it doesn't matter I only have to wait a
little bit longer soon it'll be daybreak
will it be now gonna keep talking to
yourself like a weirdo
what is it during my nightly rounds it's
vital to turn on the light in each room
for a little while it's the only way to
put everything back in order a
scientifically proven fact if the comb
is kept in order then the nightmares
will go away it is that a fact
is that really a fact what nightmares
are we talking are we calling the stabby
finally everything in its place I can
see it clearly something is wrong with
my head and still have asleep it what
what is going on oh no oh oh play back
on what oh my god are we on go to my god
oh my god do know what all I need to do
is last until sunrise dawn will put
everything in his place what does that
mean I don't it turned out to be nothing
daybreak is very close now I just have
to survive until dawn what what do you
mean what are you talking about no
you're talking about why am I going
Nestor masters I wonder with that
squeaking sound okay dope
how about nope okay how about nope stop
closing wait and watch wait watch what
we want what Ben watch what stop closing
your eyes are you dick hey I'll go dude
that's what you really want
Oh loop
Oh loop who's that
whoa that oh no no I'm not gonna waited
watch baby watch what oh right who's
right who's a black said huh no I
shouldn't have turned on that light
something was wrong in there why it's a
black actually everything's wrong in
this house once again everything's
different what is real I don't know
you're the weird one
what happened happened did I die I don't
know there was like a bed that appeared
up there I don't know what seems like
there should be a front door there but
there's not one I am so who did that who
is it
Oh me I have to hide I don't know why
but I have to hide now I was already on
my way to hide under the bed but I'm
gonna do it anyway not because you told
me oh oh goddess oh goodness
it is a sign no joke how am I gonna hide
we are getting that Oh
you
mmm
who even happened
hmm this is some game brings me back to
my childhood you hide and feel how the
time starts rolling backwards what this
is dumb pamphlet woo where am I
what's that over there I don't want to
know no don't look no light it's just my
nerves I'm not looking at not one bit
I'm not even turning my head there isn't
anything there is there something behind
hmm oh I'll only buddy my job like that
it's just rolling into my head as if
they were alive let's go I gotta this
house
dude dude dude dude oh ok nope I'm going
I'm out of here I'm gone I am out of
here
I'm out of here I'm out I'm so out until
I looks like I lost a lot of time I
guess that's a thing not even a thing oh
how do I survive ok I got him fixed the
light again I guess I guess that's the
thing I gotta do huh okay hey oh that's
a time accelerator oh crap
so that that tortas machine makes time
go ahead and III need to get that timer
all the way down so that I can get to uh
I can get to uh you know and get to the
end so what happens if I just wait here
and don't cou throughout the house is a
buy you will I to track the monsters to
me or will I will I be okay well I don't
know I I have no idea oh man this is
awesome this is so weird
this is oh wait but
oh cool oh okay gonna fix this like hmm
I saw something moving the darkness I
still think I remember in the darkness I
thought I saw something move in the dark
oh no no come d honey use it use it oh
yeah use it use it body use it buddy
oh yeah okay we don't have to wait much
longer
dawn is it coming Dawn's gonna be here
real soon and I think I think that's how
this game works I'm not exactly sure but
that's my best guess what kind of
weird-ass clock is that anyway that
doesn't make anything dong damn sense
we're just gonna wait this out alright
fine we're gonna venture nothing's
waiting for me in the darkness okay
Justin weirdly uh-huh hey oh that house
was bigger than I thought oh whoops
hi I didn't explore like any of that
house oh well good for me hide and seek
in the dark this is a test of courage so
you shouldn't really hide when you play
just try to play fair and wait for the
game to end if the seeker sees that
someone is hiding everything we'll start
from the beginning again the key is you
have to guess how the secret in seeker
interprets the game yes so if he says to
someone you're hiding but that person is
standing in the open then it is not
about being seen or not what I have no
idea but this game is so cool
I think I won now I go back in the
dreamy sleepy land wow this game is
friggin awesome
oh so cool okay so anyway I am going to
cut out for now
let me wait see what happens what
in general it's best for the psyche to
sleep soundly in the pre-dawn hours but
lately I've been awakened Restless so I
decided to spend these hours checking on
my house let's see if all the rooms are
still where they should is I mean this
is the real world or that is a real
world either way I got a I'm all out of
time so we're gonna pause it for here
this game is awesome
if you want to see more let me know in
the comments below but otherwise I'm
gonna play it anyway so you don't really
have a say in matter so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotations
for more videos and I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
Oh
you